[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes I'm joined by my
co-host Dr Greg Sadler today we're
talking about philosophical projects and
Hegel and right now I I have the great
honor of of talking
about a big project that was just
completed recently so um obviously uh Dr
Sadler here my co-host has just
completed his half hour Hegel series on
YouTube after almost a decade of work
the project is a close reading of
hegel's phenomenology Spirit Greg is a
fantastic teacher as you all probably
know and uh for his hard work he's been
great and the great honor or he's been
given the great honor of becoming a
character in existential comics and so
um yeah we should probably say what
existential Comics is for people who
aren't completely looped in so it's a
web comic right and he's been doing
stuff for probably at least a decade I
think I've been following him on Twitter
and every once in a while I gave him a
few suggestions like you know you should
put this person in your comic or put
that person in your comic and he does uh
sometimes have other contemporary
authors like I think that maybe Daniel
Dennett has been in his comic or Richard
Dawkins so yeah it was pretty cool to
find on Twitter which is where I I saw
it that he had put um a caricature of of
me into the comic now of course when we
look at the strip um it's as Comics are
a little bit
inaccurate um but it it was uh yeah it
was pretty cool to to see that happen um
I was just going to say like let's get
like the format of the comic is uh
usually have a number of usually ancient
philosophers you know some right uh you
know modernists and some that actually
contemporary and they're put in humorous
situations where they're exposing their
ideas or their philosophy and how those
sometimes interact with weird things
like uh what if um n and epic tius were
playing a game of like Monopoly together
or something like that how how does that
react and how do they react to winning
or losing you know in to his credit too
when you scroll down usually uh Corey
mhler the person who is the the Mind
behind existential Comics he'll put like
a blurb about whatever it is that he's
talking about and yeah the comic usually
isn't accurate but the blurb that he
puts puts everything in perspective and
I think if you like hover your mouse
over it there's like little Easter eggs
that you can find as as well um although
maybe Easter eggs is the wrong term
because usually it's stuff people get
excited about and I think it's just sort
of like explaining what's actually
happening which I suppose could be
exciting but often times isn't for
philosophers
right um and and so I guess like uh
because of this project you got uh
recognized and you had is a whole uh
comic that's basically dedicated to you
and your work especially on this half
hour Hegel project yeah we should we
should actually say what happens in it
so it begins with me declaring that I I
forget exactly with the formulation is
like the hardest thing in philosophy I'm
going to do that and people are like
you're going explain this you're going
to explain this and I say no I'm going
to read hegel's phenomenology of spirit
cover to cover now that's not that
difficult of a task actually I mean I
read it cover to cover back when I was
in graduate school and I think you know
I've had been reading groups about it I
think I've read it through cover to
cover probably at least 20 times at this
point but it is a you know it's a
difficult work and a lot of people start
and then once it starts getting
difficult especially in this section
called uh force and the understanding is
where people typically abandon it um and
they're like oh this is too too tough
for me so then he's got me at like I
think seven years and five years sitting
on a table just like reading this this
book and getting further into it and
then he has me take a break for uh
watching some football and it's all
Packer themed stuff which is pretty cool
you know I mean he he knows uh where we
are and then uh I finish it and then I'm
in a hospital bed because you know the
effort wore me out and the guy who's
standing next to me asks something and I
don't remember offand what it is he's
like what will you do now okay there we
go and you say I finished my work is
done okay well you say I am finished my
work is done and he is what do you do
now and then I say I'll read it again
you know yes so because it's one of
those books that um rewards rereading
well I have said that that that is like
a genuine quote from
me you know and and he's he's
exaggerating a little bit how long it
took me but not that much he says 10
years it took me 9 and A2 years it
didn't have to take me n and A2 years I
you know it is a big task right but
there there were times when I got
sidetracked by other projects and didn't
shoot any Hegel videos for a while so um
you know it probably could have got
gotten done in a shorter amount of time
if I'd really just focused on that but
life comes along and you get busy
so yeah yeah um so I guess maybe um
could you like maybe just describe the
project a little bit more in depth and
why did you start it so I mean there's a
long long backstory so this would be
like about 2000 early
2014 I
was shooting YouTube videos and the
first ones that I did were um just me
putting a flip cam down in the classroom
and like recording whatever I was
teaching about that day right and the
sound quality wasn't great and the
lighting quality wasn't wasn't great
either but it was you know it was like
actual classroom teaching and then I
started getting people making requests
and they were like uh can you do this
can you do that and I and I so I did
like a poll if I remember and I
solicited
suggestions and Jean Paul sart and
Martin haiger were like really high up
in in the
suggestions and so I did some videos on
them and then a lot of people were
asking for for Hegel I guess because
they knew I'd done some stuff on Hegel
in the past I I've actually published a
few things and so I was like yeah okay I
guess I could do this but I can't do it
the way I'm doing these other videos
where I I take like a big chunk of text
and then I summarize it over an hour um
because there's a the Temptation is to
like skip the harder parts or more
confusing parts and the problem is that
a lot of Hegel is really quite confusing
the way he writes he's he's not a great
author when it comes to style he's a
great author in terms of thought but his
his thought outruns his capacity to
clearly express it so there's a lot of
obscurity in it and I was like the only
way I could really make this work is if
I go line by line and I don't skip
anything and then I was like but how
long is that going to take you know how
will I do this so you know then I I
started thinking should I do like
hourong videos and I was like ah those
are that's maybe too much too much Hegel
for for anyone half an hour that's
that's more doable and it's got a nice
ring to it half hour Hegel right and
then I started making these like
PowerPoint slides where it's got Hegel
on one side and me on the other and the
the text and I I I I started shooting me
just reading the text um I I forget
exactly what I was in front of the for
the first ones maybe a wall or something
and then it would be there with the text
and then I would get up in front of a
chalkboard and explain at least as best
as I could um I haven't gone back to any
of these videos for a long time so maybe
they're actually not that good you um so
I I I I'd explain what was going on in
the text and I'd put stuff on the board
and and then it just sort of like took
off and and I didn't actually um start
crowdfunding it right away people were
like you know you're giving this away
for for free and I was like yeah it is a
lot of work maybe I should see I I'll go
on patreon and that's what I did for a
while um just just half hour Hegel not
my other stuff and then I I created
another one for that and it just kind of
gathered momentum I think because people
were like do you see what this crazy guy
is doing you know um says he's going to
do the whole book this way and I didn't
have any idea like how how many videos
it would take it took 375
ultimately um so you know how many hours
is that I mean
hund 10 and something 180 I I don't know
I'm I'm not good at math off the top of
my head 189 hours oh there we go yeah so
you know it but I didn't do it all at
once right you can't do something like
this all at once
um and I think if I had any inkling how
much work it would be maybe I would have
uh not done the
project um so yeah that was actually my
next question is like you know how long
do you think it would take you or did
you ever think it was going to take you
this long you had an idea that was going
to be kind of a long project but not
like nearly a decade I totally
miscalculated for some reason I thought
it would take me 2 years and even like
looking at that what I should have
projected at the time that was clearly
wrong I don't know what I was
thinking but that's what I came it was
like maybe two maybe three years I think
a reasonable amount of time would have
been like four to five years if I'd
really like just stuck to it every
single month doing like six videos for a
while I was going along at a good clip
but then I had all sorts of other things
I taught a lot you know I had semesters
where I was teaching for four different
institutions
and seeing clients and doing all sorts
of other things so you know it it is
good that I actually did finish it but I
I could have finished it a lot earlier
on I think um right but it was you know
it was kind of cool because it it
gathered some momentum people talk about
it
um online in various forums they're like
can you know is he is he actually going
to be able to do it or not you know it
gathered a kind of lore and mythology
around
it so that's that's like amazing that
like a community Grew From just like
this little thought that happened so
long ago and it's kind of flowered into
something much larger um so I guess yeah
something that people could like connect
with each other on so that that's that's
kind of nice you know yeah became the
the Nexis of a community of of sorts
yeah now you know I was thinking about
this as you were like reading our our
usual
intro does this project actually have a
lot of like you can apply this
immediately to your life hegel's not
quite so good in that way because you
have to do so much work to figure out
what the hell he's actually saying right
now once you do then some parts of it
could be interesting and applicable to
your life but um it takes a lot of work
to call those out compared to like say
Aristotle or the stoics or people that
we talk about I think much more often
right it's just it's easier to grab the
nuggets in the first place and present
them in a way that are digestible yeah
that that's a good point hegel's a tough
dish to
digest um I guess uh when you when you
started making YouTube videos did you
think that you'd still be doing it 10
years on or that even YouTube would
still be a thing 10 years after
it I think I was pretty bullish about
YouTube's prospects and when I first
started um YouTube didn't allow
individuals to do videos longer than 15
minutes when I first got on so that
would be like about
2011 and I so actually my first like
class videos were loaded not in my own
channel but in fville State University's
institutional Channel because they
institutions were allowed to upload
longer stuff and then YouTube expanded
it and then pretty soon you could like
if you want to do 4-Hour long videos
which some people did you were allowed
to do that and um I was really quite
surprised and happy about um the
feedback that I was getting in in
YouTube
comments from a lot of people both in
the fville State University videos and
then when I started teaching at Maris
College I would record intro to
philosophy or ethics uh classes later on
um
religion in America and so a lot of
people were saying things like um well
this isn't a good one but it's kind of
limited good they'd say my professor is
teaching this text but he won't explain
anything or she won't explain anything I
no need to uh think it's all men who do
that um so thanks for putting out this
video because now I can actually
understand Emmanuel Kant or Plato or
pick whatever else we were doing now
that's not good right that there's a lot
of teachers out there who won't help
their students but having that resource
out there um as something that can allow
them to understand the text that they're
supposed to be learning and enjoying
well that that's good and then you know
there were a lot of other people who
would say things like uh I can't afford
to go to college um or I had to drop out
and it's nice that you post these
because it's sort of like getting to
participate in somebody else's Class M
so I started getting you know more and
more interest in the kinds of things
that I was doing and there were many
other people doing that too there's lots
of other great um video producers and
and series out there not just in
philosophy but pick any topic you want
right oh yeah there's a number of you
know you go into a big university
oftentimes you'll have like ad junks or
yeah yeah uh what is it called student
teachers that are not the best um you
know we've actually talked about in the
past and even some professors are not
the best but you're going to have
teachers eventually that are not going
to be the best and um it's always great
to have that secondary resource and like
for um I want to say there certain
things in calculus there were um videos
that really helped me understand these
Concepts much better than uh anything I
was getting at the actual lectures yeah
you think about like so when I went to
school there was no internet at least an
undergrad the internet started becoming
part of our our uh educational
experience in in my graduate school and
so if you didn't understand what was
going on in class I mean you could go to
office hours but if you didn't
understand after that you're just kind
of screwed I mean you could maybe hire a
tutor and they could help you out but
there wasn't any there weren't a lot of
resources you could go to I I suppose
you could say like with literature we
had Cliff's Notes you know uh which
would be sort of like the you know OG
text version of all these other sites
that out there to to save your grade but
those those are kind of boring really
it's just kind of summaries of stuff
right it it wasn't somebody saying hey
I'm excited about this let me tell you
about Aristotle and friendship or you
know things along those those
lines um so uh obviously there's um like
a grand tradition of philosphers taking
long times to uh produce works yeah um I
guess trying to think of like um oh what
is it called um
oh uh Smith doing The Wealth of Nations
and also his book on which is a huge
thick book yeah yeah as well as his book
on ethics that came out before and both
those books yeah took like I want to say
a decade each um and so my thought is
what uh any insight if any did you glean
from uh thinking about a topic deeply
for this long oh yeah that's that's a
great question um
when you have to when you when you make
a commitment that you're actually going
to keep and you have to keep going back
to it you
um you learn things along the way and
and part of it actually this is kind of
a good caution there's a lot of people
who are like I want to speedrun through
stuff right and you can do that with
certain podcasts but you you really
shouldn't do that with philosophy
because you're missing stuff along the
way right so whether you're like
producing your own philosophy like Adam
Smith did or his his buddy David Hume
who wrote quite a lot of interesting
stuff as well or um somebody who's going
to come after and say that that Hume
woke him out of his dogmatic Slumber
Emmanuel Kant who's actually kind of a
late bloomer he's writing these big
thick critiques H the second one isn't
so thick but the first one is a real
headcracker and the third one is crazy
wild stuff and it's thick as well um you
if you're doing what what should we call
it like original work I think that you
you pick a topic and you like think your
way through it and you see what other
people have said and you come to your
own uh new
original synthesis integration of it you
are going to know an awful lot about
that matter and it could be history or
it could be drama it could be whatever
you want if you're doing the kind of
thing that I'm doing which is easier
where you don't have to come up with
like original thoughts of your own as a
matter of fact it's actually for a
project like half hour Hegel you don't
want somebody who's too original you
want somebody who's going to like say my
job is to figure out what the hell this
guy thinks and explain it without like
adding a lot of ideas of my own that's
that's exactly what you want with a
commentary you're still learning a lot
you're learning about that thinker and
how their work holds together
and you're also learning about the
topics that they are talking about and
maybe with somebody like Hegel you're
also like thinking
about the things that he's referring to
who's he being influenced by who is he
going to influence later on the only
original thing I would say is that you
have to come up with um examples and
ways of explaining things that make good
sense for somebody in the 21st century
right I mean hegel's writing
in uh you know more than 200 years ago
at this point so he doesn't use a lot of
examples period and the ones that he
uses are let's say a little bit dated
you know really so so there's that and
and I will say this too this is a little
bit of a
digression good teaching I think at
least with certain topics and I'd be
interested to see see what you think
about this like what other topics this
would
apply to you really need to be able to
come up with examples and analogies that
your your audience your students can
connect with you know if you're trying
to like like with today's um students I
almost said kids but they're not kids
they're like 18 to 24 year olds so if if
you want to talk about like Star Trek
they they don't watch Star Trek they
don't have any clue what the hell you're
talking about so if you're going to say
yeah there's this guy Spock and is like
super
logical if they watch Star Trek it's not
the original series it's going to be uh
you know Voyager or it'll probably the
the newest stuff like the discovery or
um New World cartoon um lower decks
lower deck right I love yeah yeah I mean
you could use those sorts of things I
mean I I'd be interested to see like how
long Rick and Morty retains a shelf life
that's a very philosophical Series right
um but I think 10 years from now none of
that's going to be helpful so you you
got to find examples that contemporary
people can relate to but are also going
to have a shelf life that's longer than
just some pop culture stuff you know so
I guess I would say you asked me about
this and I agree and it's it's not just
finding one example it's it's finding
several examples cuz you're never going
to find one example that's going to hit
gr oh like you know like this this this
example works for this group and this
example works for this group and you
know and on and on and so the ability to
quickly come up with like a number of
different examples is you know a thing
that I look for in really good
teachers it's something that's hard to
teach too I mean there are lots of
classes that you can take in Ed
departments about like how you should
teach how to be a good teacher but
figuring out how to do that that's
that's you have to go to you have to go
to people like Cicero for that and and
look at the topics or um i' I've always
said it because teaching is in part
performance that it that's right um
would behoove someone uh to take at
least a little bit of theater or drama
um and specifically in this case um
improv okay yeah all about associations
constant associations and how can you
you grab something and smash them
together and uh try to convey
something I think you're right that that
probably would be helpful
for well not just early on teachers I
mean there's a lot of older teachers who
probably could use a tuneup you know
some professional development as we call
it you know uh well speaking of uh
tuneups maybe you can tune us up with um
if you have any ideas from Hegel that
you would like to share maybe something
we might want to talk about in detail
later on yeah so you know Hegel
is wellknown in the areas that he is
wellknown because I think he's he's not
all that well known he was he was huge
in the 19th century and I would say um
for a good part of the 20th
century um but he's he's not all that
much read today but one of his big Ideas
was that our human consciousness and
rationality has developed historically
so history actually does matter and you
can say that we're not the same human
beings as people were back in in you
know the Middle Ages or Antiquity now
Hegel has a very eurocentric sort of
point of view on this um you know it's
Europe is where all the cool stuff is
happening maybe we need to abandon that
um but I do like this idea that you know
it's not as if human rationality was
just there in the time of the ancient
Greeks and and it hasn't Advanced since
then I think that um the ways in which
we organize society and I I would say
Hegel couldn't think of technology in
the ways that we do but technology
really plays a major role the place
where I disagree with Hegel is that he
thought that history had effectively
finished up around his time and he
thought that that was necessary in order
to be able to like look back and have
like a a full view on
things I think it's clear history hasn't
ended all sorts of new stuff has has
come about and um so you know the
question then is well how do we what do
we do with this guy and his his Works
can we still use them and the answer is
yeah kind of you know there there are
people out there who are like and I'm
I'm not a hegelian in the sense of like
a True Believer uh but there are some
True Believers out there who they they
up with these incredibly complex charts
and it's almost like you know in that
that uh meme that's coming from almost
Sunny where you got uh Charlie Day and
he's got all of these crazy connections
right Hegel like that right um and and
there are some people who try to do that
sort of thing but I I don't think that's
that's super successful I do like um a
lot of the more individual ual parts of
his Works where he'll say here was part
of the dynamic that was going on because
I think you can sometimes take those and
say Here's what's going on in society at
this time or here's what's going on in
my interpersonal
relationships he can be useful for that
but it takes a lot of work to make that
applicable um so I
guess forgive me if I I'm I'm not as
verse in Hegel as you are so you're
you're saying you talk about like the
idea of his like the end of History yeah
so instead of like just this end point
that we can still use his ideas about
using I guess hisan dialectic as a um a
lens to see history as a just a constant
looking at instead of a thinking of this
is a finality yeah and and we don't have
to think that it's all completely
resolved um in order to think that we
have a good view I should mention to
that when when we talk about the
hegelian dialectic that's not the
caricature of thesis antithesis
synthesis followed by another one that's
actually a different guy that's that's a
fcta who's earlier and then U Marx will
use something like that but Hegel
himself although he does love threes he
doesn't actually arrange things quite
like that but but dialectical philosophy
I mean that's that's part of what
hegel's modeling for us the idea that
when you have
a what looks like it's the finished
product it's never quite finished and
there's always like something that's
going to come out of it by way of
opposition to it that'll add something
new to the mix and sometimes it'll be a
challenge some sometimes it'll be a
critique sometimes it'll be like a
rivalry and then you got to see how
things play themselves out and and it
you know I've seen this sort of thing
adapted in a lot of interesting
circumstances there's a um um military
analyst who I used to really like um
Edward lvoc unfortunately he's really
past his prime now and and just sort of
like rambling on Twitter about crazy
stuff I think he he might have had some
problems um but he wrote this book
called strategy the logic of War and
Peace and he is using a hegelian
framework to explain like why aircraft
carriers are not the great investment
that they look like in the
1980s um while Appropriations are going
on and he and he's he's explaining it in
a hegelian way which I guess kind of
makes sense because there was
this military theorist called clausewitz
who also was a
hegelian and he's sort of like one of
the early modern military theorists and
and I think litvac is influenced by and
so there's all sorts of interesting like
Hegel fertilized this Hegel fertilized
that but the one thing that you can say
is like everybody who's doing something
with this guy is doing their own thing
with him you know so I just you when
you're talking about the aircraft car
I'm thinking about like I guess through
the history of the military there's
always a new invention that for the time
being sets a new status quo and it's
like oh this is the best strategy or
this is the best piece of equipment or
the combination always be like this then
forward yeah until the next thing and
then the next thing and so like you know
for a long time like tanks were amazing
and now with drones tanks are not nearly
as amazing because you can have a a
couple million dollar pieces of
equipment taken out with you know $300
of uh you know rotors and a mortar
attached to it yeah you have to do
combined arms which is something that
that developed as well and and the other
thing too I'll say Hegel presents
history as if it's like a set of
advances like you're you're never going
to go back and I think he's wrong about
that I think sometimes we can
regress um or at least parts of the
world can can regress you know so yeah
and I'm just thinking like u in the
1960s right um like you had the whole
you know uh at least in the United
States we have this um uh what is that
the the year of love the um oh summer 69
you mean yeah the summer 69 and
Woodstock and and this whole Counter
Culture Revolution that's happening but
you know within 10 years there's a a
counter to that counter Revolution which
is kind of regressive in response to
that it's like no no no we can't go that
far forward we have to come back yeah
and and I would say I'd agree at least
in that one uh with that as an
example yeah yeah and I mean politically
it seems that on at least some issues
we're we've got a lot of people who
would like to see a regression and going
back to some you know era when they
thought America was better um usually
those turn out to be pretty mythological
but um it's it's definitely there and
and and it's not just here it's we're
seeing this in a lot of other countries
as well um I don't know what Hegel would
make of that um I mean if you were to
bring him into our present he would have
so much culture shock that he would have
to like get over just to be able to
cognize what the hell is going
on so do do you think you'd have the
ability to um how's that end the book
get to Absolute knowledge of the current
oh
mode yeah that's that's another
interesting thing so I think a lot of
people that are interested in Hegel or
or other thinkers of his sort they've
got this catchphrase uh completing the
system of German idealism right and that
was so German idealism starts with a
Manuel Kant and then like moves forward
through a couple generations and Hegel
is at sort of a high point of that and
everybody was talking about systems and
everyone was talking about like finally
completing this like you have a synoptic
view of everything right and that's
that's what absolute knowing would be
right um and I just don't think that's
actually possible I think they believed
it was possible back then but I don't
think you you do complete any systems
whether they are German idealism or pick
something else down the line um the best
that we get is kind of fragmentary and
and it's interesting because Hegel was
living in a time when you could at least
have the illusion of having like read
everything and studied everything right
there there was wasn't quite as much out
there um now obviously Hegel didn't read
everybody and everything but you know
it's not like today in philosophy or
pick any other discipline where I mean
you can't possibly read more than just a
little fraction of what's available and
you're always dealing with things like
am I reading the right thing should I
spend time on this rather than on this
you know and anybody who tries to tell
you like I have the definitive answer
that you know they're full of crap you
know because how could they possibly
know you know it's it's a serious
epistemological problem concerned with
our knowledge right but Hegel could at
least at that time think that it was
possible and so that probably emboldened
him to do the kind of work that he was
doing you know because if you don't
think it's possible you're not going to
write a book where everything gets
solved you know
yeah um well I I Revel in the um
unknowing because there's always
something more to investigate I think
that makes it fun too um not having I
mean some people get very pessimistic
about that right they're like I'll never
read all of this and I I actually had I
don't know if you've ever had this
experience so I would go into our
University Library when I was at
Southern Illinois University at
Carbondale and it turned out that was
actually a great research library and
you'd walk down like the you know
philosophy Isles and You' look at these
books like collected works of Hegel
schopenhauer heiger you know all all
these people in the German section
you'll be like Jesus I'll never read all
of this stuff and even if I do I'll
forget most of it by the time that I've
actually read it and I'll only get like
this bookshelf done I won't get all
those other things done maybe this whole
like studying philosophy thing is really
a waste of my time because I can't ever
do that um and so it's it's quite easy
to feel a sense of Despair I think have
you ever had that with the things that
you were studying like you go on the
library and you're like there's just too
many books I'm never gonna I'm never
going to even figure out which ones are
the best ones you know I don't know I
think I had kind of a
um maybe a moment closer to like looking
at the universe and realizing it's so
incredibly Mast that I'm never going to
be able to know it all but it's okay
because I'm at least part of it and I'm
experiencing part of it and so like I
think of you know you go into any
discipline the more that you go into the
discipline you more that you know right
right that the discipline holds and yeah
you you do you have this moment it's
like
well I'm going to do this like and I I I
love the idea that like any time that I
meet a person they know something that I
don't know and and there's always a
place for me to have something new I
can't ever just go to a person and
totally dismiss miss them because
there's something some you even it's
just like interpersonal thing that they
know um that is uh can be interesting
and and I I guess I I Revel in the
exploration yeah I and I think that's a
healthy way to to view these things cuz
otherwise it could be a real Downer you
know I mean the people who are like ah
there's nothing ever new it's all the
same boring BS I mean how the hell would
you ever know that you know
um so uh I went back and I I watched
your very first video of the half hour
heel series and I wouldn't watch the
very last video of your half half hour
Hegel series um and sweet I've noticed
that you've grown such a more impressive
beard um in that time uh so I the
question is um does Hegel cause beard
growth by impressive you mean whiter
right uh well it was very short um
that's true yeah yeah yeah I and that's
that's more a function of laziness you
know I I don't trim it as often as as I
used to every once's in a while I'll
give it a good clip and then you can you
can actually tell in the videos when I
do that um but yeah at that time um I
don't think there was any white in my
hair my my mustache my beard um yeah
some people actually there you know that
um that Meme or it wasn't a meme
originally I think it was like from
commercial where they're like they show
somebody before and after it's for like
heroin and meth and stuff like that
somebody did that about three or four
years ago with with one of my early
pictures and then you know later on and
you see like you know I've got wrinkles
now this your mind on philosophy or
something or Hegel this what happens
when you read
Hegel so yeah I mean um it's it I mean
it hasn't aged me um but I've definitely
aged it's it's 10 years and it's kind of
striking um how much difference that
makes I'm 53 years old I guess I
probably was 43 when I started yeah so
yeah oh um guess uh how's it feel to be
you know cartoonified and uh did you
have any uh forn knowledge of the comic
coming out uh yeah you know I didn't um
and it was kind of a pleasant surprise
to see it um I follow Cory Mohler
existential comics in in Twitter by the
way I'll say this by way of digression
um some of the funniest stuff he ever
did was not so much in the comic strip
he before Elon Musk purchased Twitter
and this is like going back years and
years and years um musk would get into
Twitter beefs with people and Cory
Mohler was one of those people and he
was just zinging them you know and it
was it was almost like watching um an
unequal struggle because you know muskus
is supposed to be This brilliant guy and
he's got this uh cartoonist just running
circles around
him saying stuff to him making him look
foolish and it was almost like uh in
comedy they talk about the straight guy
meaning the guy who's not funny but
we'll say stuff and the funny guy gets
to play off of him uh mhler was doing
that with m
um he was just giving him the old rope a
doe you know uh so so anyway I I've been
following Mohler stuff for for a long
time and and I will say this too you
can't be funny all the time not every
not every um strip lands completely but
there is something to be said for
perseverance I don't know how many he's
done but it's way up it's got to be at
least 500 maybe more uh yours was
517 well there you go see so um and he's
done uh one more so he's at 518
currently so the the the amount of like
commitment and work involved that that's
really something you know and oh
absolutely doing cartoons I mean I can't
do that sort of thing so anyway yeah I
saw it come out uh in Twitter and I was
like holy crap you know and then I
posted it in in in my own social media
and a lot of other people weighed in on
it and they liked it you know quite a
bit um they thought it was pretty funny
and and uh then I actually turned it
into a YouTube short I took each of the
panels and um put them in there and I
did a voice
over for it yeah I watched it it was fun
I I I small critique I think you could
have done um some more varied voices for
the non-ra salor but I I did a high
pitch thing for them you know but I I
yeah there were there were the three at
one point I should have like done three
different characters or something uh but
I think I just wanted to get it out
right away you know yeah um so um one
Corey posted this thing onal Comics um
he has the comic that we' talked about a
little bit but he also has as we talked
about beforehand a little blurb after
that actually goes into things in a more
rigorous way and so from existential
Comics under this comic it goes this
comic is in tribute to Gregory Sadler
finishing his half hour Hegel in which
he does a close reading of hegel's
phenomenology Spirit one of philosophy's
most notoriously long and difficult
Works he started February 27th 2014
nearly 10 years ago yeah just a few
months after I started this comic and he
finished with his 377th video Last
Friday September 21st
2023 finally explaining the concept of
absolute knowing and also hitting
hinting that he might reread it if uh
from the very start now come on man give
Hegel a rest to me this is one of the
longest and most dedicated YouTube
projects that I know of especially
consider that heel isn't as popular of a
subject matter as say silly cats so if
you have a spare 189 hours or so for
Hegel give it a
listen he also says to go and um you
know donate to your patreon so that's
nice yeah I'll and then I am closing
down the half hour Hegel patreon though
because and just going to my regular one
because they Project's over you know um
I am actually G to I I have applied the
same methodology to epicus andcan which
is a much much shorter work much more
manageable I think that was around 20
videos or so and I'm planning on doing
an anom of canterbury's prian and
another nice short work that could use
use that
attentiveness next and then I'm going to
do Renee decart's um meditations on
first philosophy which
interestingly is I I'm using a text that
has the Original Latin because deart did
not write it in French he actually had
as a French speaker he had another guy
translate it from the Latin into the
French so I'll be like referring to the
the Latin the French and then the the
sort of received English translation and
that should be fun and then I'll I'll
pick another big book and people people
have been like you should do hegel's
science of logic next and I'm like nope
somebody else can do that you know
division of labor man um and then
they're like do heiger being in time or
do Lon cre and I I don't think I'm going
to do those I'll I'll probably do
something like sarts being a nothingness
um but we'll see I I'm GNA Pace myself
now too and I've I've uh CRI from your
style because um to a certain extent I
do that uh with my Stoke group that I
run on uh Sundays oh the close reading
thing you mean yeah yeah I do close
we've beening you started doing iners
stuff again right that's kind of a big
deal for yeah yeah um and so we've been
doing a close reading of um the moral
letters of senica to
lucilius um or lucilius um and uh yeah
it's been really fun like you know we'll
maybe get through you know or maybe
we'll go through a half a letter or a
quarter of letter depending letter but
you know especially like with that that
dialogue and back and forth and like gu
let's talk about this thing and that
thing and go deeper into that and it
references this work or that work it's
very fun yeah I mean I think some people
would be like oh why are you spending so
much time on that let's get through the
work but that like lingering over it um
it gives you the freedom to have
conversations and then learn from those
conversations that you you you otherwise
wouldn't do you know and and you can't
if you're going to do like a I'm not
going to skip anything when you get to
something that doesn't make sense you
can't just say well doesn't make sense
let's move on you gota like figure out
like well what the hell is it going on
here how can I explain this right right
as well as like it gives me the the
opportunity to like really pick out
things that I might disagree with like I
like senica for the most part but like
hey here's the thing one we we we know
more about the world we know more about
how people and and things work um and
he's just wrong about that that's okay
uh we can we can still work through this
and and see what is actually interesting
and useful yet I also find a little bit
suspect his you know doesn't matter that
I'm super rich I'm just as good of a
stoic as anybody else you know yeah it's
like we we were talking about one is
like oh yes I um I had the slave and
he's he's my pacemaker I go running
every morning but he's too fast for me
so I to find a different slave to be my
pacemaker it's like oh my God not a
problem we're we're we're posed with uh
these days that's that's for sure
um uh but we also have a whole bunch of
like these uh really great uh comments
from YouTube and Twitter in response to
this thing so um uh here's one from
YouTube uh be before following the half
hour Hegel series since day one uh just
want to uh express my deep gratitude to
your effort in making technical philos
content accessible and you will and your
will to complete this Monumental project
it was pivotal in fulfilling my
continued interest in German idealism
and seeing hegel's footprint on the
history of philosophy thank you Dr
Sadler you are the pref professor I wish
I had during my undergrad years this is
from um uh JW yeah yeah yeah that's
that's a that's a really nice one and
there were a lot of uh very nice
comments like that um there were quite a
few people who um talked about like they
might not have worked through hegel's
text if they didn't
have this project to help them see it
through and that so that's great I mean
there's probably books that would be
equally important to read but here's
this one right um and then you know
that's really kind of nice too you're
the professor I wish had I wish I'd had
during my undergrad years I I kind of
resonate with that cuz my professors
were were terrible My Philosophy
professors some of my other disciplines
they were quite good but my two
undergrad philosophy professors were
like they were guys who didn't have much
of an interest in the discipline because
they were older and they had other stuff
going on and other projects and so I did
a lot of learning on my own you know and
it's it's fortunate that I like was able
to do that because I think a lot of
students need somebody to kind of help
them along you
know making a connection here it might
be totally wrong um but uh often times
it will ask you like who to read or
whose commentaries read and you're like
just read the original authors you know
you'll get much more from reading them
then you will from the vast majority
secondary works yeah yeah um and yet I
produced a commentary yeah um is that in
part maybe due to the fact that you did
not have really good professors to give
you their commentary working through the
work and thus you were forced kind of to
actually directly deal with the works
themselves yeah that's actually a great
question I I'm I'm sure that that's part
of it um now when I got to graduate
school I had good professors I mean I
also had some bad ones too but but
plenty of good ones and not just in
philosophy too there was a guy in speech
Communications who taught some really
cool stuff and a guy in English who
taught really cool stuff on rhetoric and
I got to study with the classics
Department which was cool as well for my
my uh Greek um you know reading Plato
and Aristotle and Herodotus and people
like that um so yeah I think that that
probably is part of it the other thing
though I mean I did read secondary works
and I what I found was so there was this
I'll use one as an example there's this
very
popular uh
writer will Durant and he's got this
book called The Story of philosophy and
you know it's a history of philosophy
and it's kind of selective like they
always are leaves some people out and I
took his word that he actually knew what
the hell he was talking about and then I
would go and read the thinkers that he
had told me about like um Arthur
schopenhauer you know hre beron and I
discovered that he was he was uh very
glib but kind of full of crap
and if I had trusted him on that I would
have been LED astray and and probably
not actually read certain thinkers and
so I I think it's good to read the
thinkers for yourself even if even if
they are difficult because then you
actually see what they're saying you
know there's a lot of like bad takes out
there about Plato or Aristotle or or the
stoics I mean just think of the
misrepresentations of the stoics that
run throughout 19th and 20
Century philosophy and so we we want to
actually like go to the primary text
when we can when we have the luxury of
doing so and seeing what these people
actually did think about stuff and and I
I I kind of think of it it's not just
about like making sure that you have it
right why would you want to deprive
yourself of the enjoyment and
opportunity to read these really great
thinkers you know I mean imagine if like
instead of
reading I know let's transpose it into
um sci-fi and fantasy right I mean you
can read summaries of tolken The Lord of
the Rings but that's not the same thing
as reading the Lord of the Rings you
know um why not actually read the tolken
and and see what's what's there you know
um I mean you could actually watch the
movies too right and you'd be like yeah
I know exactly what happens yeah but the
movies aren't quite the same thing no
you know
although yes they're they're different
um I'd say that
there's they're closer they're closer
than a lot of adaptations right yeah
there's no Tom Bombadil and depending on
how much you like Tom bomil that's
either a bonus or a subtraction from it
yeah I mean this is a total other
tangent and we've talked about this like
when we talked about Philip K dick and
and Blade Runner and uh man not man in
the High Castle uh do Android's dream of
El sheep right often times the
adaptations of Philip K dick are very
loose let's say right right part because
it's really hard to describe what Philip
K dick is is doing in a visual medium
yeah like there's lots of internal
monologue and and and or at least
experiences that they're saying that are
really hard to properly give uh visual
representation yeah I'm not sure how you
know I can criticize all oh you left
this out I don't know how the hell I
would put like mercerism in or in man in
the High Castle the Reliance on the eing
the the Oracle which is just people like
throwing yo stocks down and then looking
in a book that doesn't make for very
good TV drama you know right um so going
back we've got a couple of other um
comments of people responding to this um
there's one from Twitter congrats my
friend for being immortalized in a silly
internet philosophy comic the the
highest honor one can receive it's from
this weird guy oh he get his go pack go
as well um I think his name is Dan Hayes
yeah Dan ha
yeah that is a good one yeah I
immortalized I guess in a certain sense
you you're immortalized because the
internet's out there forever right if
they take it down there's the way back
machine right um but they've already
moved on
yes obviously this is all a bit of like
exaggeration but it was fun and then um
Corey um from existential Comics says uh
the greatest ambition of philosophy um
congrats to Greg SAR for completing the
half hour Hegel series after like 10
years or whatever I love the little
irreverence or whatever in that and
there that I mean that is a really funny
thing to say though the greatest
ambition of philosophy I mean is this is
this even remotely close I don't think
so I mean in YouTube okay I don't I
don't actually know maybe it actually is
the
longest series on a philosophical text
there's probably a good chance that
that's the case but you know 10 years
from now there'll be somebody else who
did like a 800 video series on somebody
I I'm willing to bet
right right and and like you everyone's
got their moment in the Sun and just
happens to be yours yeah and I think
this sun is actually starting to set on
it
too um and uh uh uh Nomad xilio says
that's why he's the goat the
goat again that's what I mean the goat
stands for the greatest of all time um
that's probably undeserved and uh even
if I am that right now in terms of this
one limited thing of doing YouTube video
series on philosophy somebody's probably
going to come along and do a longer one
yeah you know they'll just pick a longer
book you know you know records are made
to be broken that's why they're
like I mean it is it is kind of cool
because we you know we can we can
recognize like think about football
right so the stuff that when When We
Were Young we saw athletes doing has
been long surpassed right almost all
them yeah but you know it doesn't mean
they didn't do anything you know
especially like they they increase the
season so you have more games to score
more points or run more yards or throw
more you know like on then you have to
like oh now you have to like extrapolate
well if you do this as averages would
they have extended their their ability
to continue doing this for a 16 or 17
Game season it's always stuff is always
changing um I will say something off
topic about that though that's really
quite funny because there is another um
Twitter account that I follow called
Super 70 sports that posts all these
pictures of like you know different
sports people and popular culture from
the 70s and 80s and one of the things
that you see that's just crazy with
these football players is they're like
sitting on the sideline puffing away on
a cigarette you know doing things that
nowadays you know we would considered
just be like over the top right and you
know they'll have their helmet off and
they're drinking a beer or something and
you're like holy crap that's what they
did back then uh total digression on
your digression there's there's a oh I
can't remember what the heck his name is
there's a
pitcher that wasn't expecting to be
having to go pitching and so he'd taken
a whole bunch of
assing and then he his coach C like
where the hell are you so he ran over to
the uh the baseball field and pitched a
no
[Laughter]
hitter yeah that the sort of stuff that
people did routinely back then was was
just crazy yeah I was like you know you
know smoking and drinking beer in the in
the Dugout and oh got to go up there and
you know hit that ball play G since
we're like throwing around stories
before we run out of time when I was in
the Army so this would be like late 80s
early 90s um we had to run five miles
every morning because we were we were
combat troops and it was just expected
of us and so us younger guys everybody
smoked because it was super cheap there
were no state taxes so you could buy
like a whole carton of cigarettes for
seven bucks so we would bring a pack of
cigarettes to the run and there'd be
like a lighter in it and it was almost
like a relay race one guy would would
get a cigarette out and he'd light it
and he'd take a puff you know nice big
drag because he he wasn't going to get
it for a while then he'd hand it to the
guy in front of him and that guy would
take a drag and if he was a non-smoker
he just push it up the line right and
the older guys would be looking at us
like you you you're just sick you know
what is wrong with you people but we
were in such great shape that it didn't
it didn't like make us feel winded or
anything that's what we did WOW uh the
things that we do in our youth right
yeah well I think we we're we're
actually getting close to the end of
hour aren't we so um all the superent Ts
for you there Greg and we leave you
today with the words of G gorg Wilhelm
Friedrich Hegel the owl of minurva
spreads its wings only with the falling
of the
dusk
[Music]
oh